Opposers, this can't wait.
The Opposition's
very own Kobi Libii
has confronted
a potential crisis actor
posing as the real Alex Jones
in Washington D.C..
On Sandy Hook
and all the people that look
and act like actors.
You look at
the Aurora shooting
that was totally staged.
And they may actually even have
some experience in uh, you know
acting.
Now I want to be clear,
we didn't call
this Alex Jones crisis actor
"a crisis actor".
We merely looked
at the crisis actor
like-behavior of
this crisis actor like man
speaking from
what felt like a script
and said others might say
"Alex Jones is a crisis actor".
Besides, that sad sorry man
looks nothing like the real A.J.
I'm supposed to believe
that guy gave advice
to the President
of the United States?
No way. Sad.
The fight continues.
You, are you a deep state
operative who's sent by George
Soros
to take away my
Second Amendment rights
to force feed me soy burgers?
No? Well then prove it.
Click and subcribe
and join The Opposition. Now.